let's consider the motion of a car on a
circular track and the track is
frictionless and it's also banked so
this is the overhead view of our
circular track it has a radius R and
here's our car moving at a constant
velocity now from the side view when we
want to look at that Bank turn let's
draw a side view so here's our side view
and the car is moving with the velocity
into the plane of the figure now this
surface here is frictionless and what
we'd like to do is find out what speed
the car can move such that it doesn't
slide up or down the inclined plane so
how should we analyze that well our
approach will be to apply Newton's
second law x' now what's very important
to realize is this is circular motion
and for circular motion we know that the
car is accelerating towards the center
of the circle now from the side view
towards the center of the circle is in
this direction so the car is
accelerating radially inward and that
will guide how we choose our coordinate
system and so we can then write our free
body force diagram so let's begin with
the analysis so we don't need to see the
overhead view anymore so I'll just
remove that and then we can start
drawing this is what we can refer to as
our acceleration diagram and now let's
draw the force diagram on the car as our
choice of system so here's our angle fee
because the acceleration was inward
we're going to choose a radially outward
coordinate and a vertical coordinate K
add up notice that this is different
than just a mass on a fixed inclined
plane where we used unit vectors up and
down the inclined plane the reason we
choose our unit vectors like that to
emphasize it again is we already know
this is constrained motion it's circular
motion
now what are the free body what are the
forces on the car well there's the
normal force the plane on the car and
the gravitational force
now here whenever you're doing problems
like this remember that the trig is
crucial to get these angles right so
that's the and that's C and that's our
free body force diagram and now we can
write down Newton's second law so we'll
start out with our usual approach and we
have two directions that we have to
consider so in the radial direction
there's an inward component of the
normal force like that and that's
opposite the angle so it's pointing
opposite our direction so we have minus
and sine fee the gravitational force is
only in the negative K out direction and
we know that the acceleration is inward
and so there's a minus sign we have the
mass and the constraint for circular
motion is that that's B squared over R
where R was the radius of that circle
this can be thought of as a central
central point now for the K hat
direction we have a component of the
normal force that's pointing up I'll
just draw that that's adjacent to the
angle so we have plus + cosine fee and
we have the gravitational force downward
minus mg and as far as the vertical
direction goes because the car is going
in a circle there is no acceleration up
or down in the vertical direction again
that's a constraint in this problem
that's equal to zero
so in this problem this is the side that
we know and we're trying to figure out
up to the speed V now how do we analyze
this problem well you can see that if I
write my two equations is and sine fee
equals MV squared over R + and cosine
fee equals mg we have two equations we
have two unknowns vnn many times people
just solve for n
and try to find the equation and then
substitute it in but you're also allowed
to divide two equations and that's much
easier the masses cancel and we get the
relationship that tan P is V squared
over R G and so we have our result that
the speed that the car can travel on a
frictionless inclined plane and maintain
uniform circular motion is exactly the
square root of RG 10 feet and that's how
we analyze the motion of this car in a
bank turn what we would now like to
think about is what would happen if
you're traveling faster or slower than
this speed so suppose we have V prime
bigger than the speed now what what that
means is that the car is going faster
and the new equilibrium if you asked
what would the radius be such that
traveling at V prime the car undergoes
circular motion the prime would be equal
to R prime G tan fee and so in order to
go at this speed you have to go at a
greater radius now what does that mean
well that means that if the car is
traveling at V so it's in this circular
motion and now the driver increases the
speed to V Prime the car will start to
slide up the inclined plane remember
it's frictionless until it reaches a as
it starts slide up the inclined plane it
will get to this new radius R prime but
because a car will have a little nurse'
it will overshoot that speed that radius
and then it will start to come back down
the inclined plane and it will oscillate
about that point it won't be sinusoidal
oscillations but there'll be a periodic
oscillation about this new radius R
the same thing too if we have the double
Prime less than V then the double prime
is equal to our double prime G tan fee
now remember this double prime is not
two derivatives I'm just using that as a
notation to indicate different speeds so
if the car is going along at speed V and
slows down what will happen is the new
equilibrium radius is smaller so the car
slides down the inclined plane until it
gets to our double prime it turns out
that it will overshoot that a little bit
and then start to move up and again it
will oscillate around this new
equilibrium length so on a frictionless
inclined plane if you go faster this
speed the car slides up if you go slower
than the speed the car slides down